what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and in this video i
will break down one of the most
horrifying twists in the history of mha
dobby's real backstory was finally
revealed including the dark truth about
how he became a villain the villains
have been conducting horrible
experiments on children and dobby was
one of them what's more it looks like
dobby may actually be a human and nomu
hybrid so let's get into it you guys
know the drill if you enjoy these videos
and you want to see more in the future
just leave a quick like and comment it
only takes a second but it really helps
with that youtube algorithm and remember
that subscribing and hitting that
notification bell is a very real and
completely free way of directly
supporting the channel you can also hit
me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror finally this video will of
course contain boku no hero manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned the latest
installment of the story starts off
inside the police station where ujico is
currently being held from inside his
dark jail cell ujico starts speaking to
one of the cops a guy whose mutation
type quirk gives him the appearance of a
gorilla ujiko says it has already
started hasn't it the cop tries to
telujiko to shut up but the doctor keeps
going ujico noticed that the number of
police officers at the station has been
reduced and he deduces that this is
because of the severe staffing shortages
that are occurring due to all the
unprecedented villain activity ujico
says that the villains had been planning
for a long time for this very moment and
then he reveals a truly terrifying truth
a truth that explains dobby's full
backstory and a lot more about all for
one's secret master plan we jump 11
years into the past and we see the
immediate aftermath of toya nearly
burning to death on secure hill we were
all wondering what actually happened to
toya after the fire and how he came to
be a villain known as dabi clearly
someone had to have helped him because
he would have been severely injured but
we didn't know who helped him and what
exactly happened after that although we
did have our suspicions well those
suspicions have just been confirmed
because it turns out that all for one
himself was the one who rescued toyah i
mean we don't see his face but from his
build and his clothes it seems pretty
clear that it's all for one as the
flames engulfed toya's body the boy was
fiercely determined to survive because
he wanted so desperately to show his
father what he could do he wanted so
desperately to impress endeavor with his
abilities and to finally make his father
proud and because toya continued to
cling to life all for one was able to
locate him and take him away to a secret
location after three full years of being
in a coma toya finally wakes up inside
what appears to be some sort of
children's hospital school there are
other children here and when toyah wakes
up the children seem excited that quote
unquote mr sleepyhead is finally awake
the entire scene is very surreal there
are children's arts and crafts all over
the wall and the vibe in general is very
friendly except we all know that there
is some scary stuff going on just
beneath the surface
and toyah's face which was supposed to
have been burned off along with the rest
of his body seems to have healed i mean
he has large scars and stitches on his
face which gives toya a frankenstein
monsters kind of vibe but he looks a lot
better than he should have knowing what
he has been through toya has no idea
where he is and when he speaks he is
surprised by his own voice his voice
seems different than it was before the
other kids tell toya that he is quote
unquote home which is again super creepy
and they also explained to him that he
has been asleep for three whole years
toya has no idea what happened to him
and the last thing he remembers is
burning up in the fire on secure hill he
decides that he has to go back home
right now and then just when i thought
that things couldn't get any creepier
one of the i guess teachers shows up
this teacher is a muscular guy who has
the face of a happy childish flower for
some reason and flower face guy explains
that toya cannot go home because this is
his new home and the other kids are his
new family he also says that toya is
sure to warm up to the other kids
quickly which is just just i have no
words anyway toy is like hold up bro
that pun was terrible but also i have a
family and they are probably worried
about me and looking for me toya tries
to tell himself that endeavor was
probably just too busy to come and see
him on secure hill that day but he's
probably worried sick now and he needs
to apologize to his mom and the others
for disappearing for three years at this
point it's clear that despite what
happened on secure hill toya is still
determined to earn his father's approval
however
a voice from a computer then begins to
speak to toya and it says that toes
plans to return home are no longer
possible we don't actually see who is
speaking from the computer the screen is
just completely dark but we can assume
that it must be either all for one or
ujiko all for one has done this type of
computer communication stuff multiple
times in the past but since ujico is the
one who is telling the story it could be
him the voice explains that toya's body
was burned down to almost nothing and
the procedure of putting his body back
together was an extreme one it seems
that his current skin and other tissue
has been grafted onto him presumably
from other people's bodies and this is
essentially how frankenstein's monster
was also created so i find this parallel
very interesting and i mean it's almost
certain that horikoshi is making this
parallel on purpose dobby's current face
and much of the rest of his skin is not
actually his own he might look similar
to his former self but he is essentially
wearing the skin of other people again
super creepy vibes in this entire
chapter the voice on the computer goes
on to state that toya won't be able to
use his quirk like he did before he has
damaged multiple organs his nervous
system is impaired and he won't be able
to feel pain and normally anymore
essentially his perception of pain has
been dulled and on top of that his body
has become weaker overall and he will
never be the same again the voice then
provokes doya by calling him a failure
he is a failure because the procedure
couldn't bring him back to his full
strength but when toya hears those words
he is reminded of his father and how his
father treated him nevertheless the
voice does say that toya may be able to
get his firepower back to what it was
before but only if he stays in this
facility and becomes part of this creepy
family the true purpose of this facility
was essentially to groom children to
become spare vessels for all for one in
case his top choice which was of course
tenkoshimura failed to meet his
expectations for whatever reason and
speaking of shigaraki aka tenko if you
go back to chapter
235 a man with a suit and hat is seen
bringing young tenko home after he was
apparently playing hiro somewhere
outside this man looks very similar to
the man who found the toya so this is
yet more evidence that the man who
brought tenko home that day was all for
one and it's pretty clear that all for
one had been watching tenko long before
tenko accidentally killed his family it
seems that toya had been a candidate to
become a spare vessel because of the
insane power of his quirk but the
deterioration of his body made him a
less than ideal candidate either way
though ujico says that it was too late
for toya at this point he was already
completely driven by his obsession to
get approval from endeavour that seemed
to be his sole driving force and so he
refused to remain in the facility he
eventually unleashed his quirk burned
the facility down
and escaped ujico warns the gorilla cop
that toya aka dabi is far worse than the
heroes can even imagine he is so
unhinged that even the villains couldn't
keep him under control ujico didn't know
how dobby even managed to survive as
long as he did because apparently after
waking up and still choosing to keep
using his quirk his body shouldn't have
lasted even a month but dobby did
survive and eventually he reappeared
when he joined the league of villains
upon his return dobby was clearly aware
that ujiko was the one who saved his
life all those years ago at this stage
dabi implies that he was kept alive
using the same technology that was used
to create the nomu which by the way is
freaking insane and that explains why
dobby's body hasn't been incinerated
even though he uses incredibly
overpowered flames without having a
resistance to those flames dobby seems
to be some sort of human nomu hybrid so
his ability to withstand damage and
tolerate pain are far beyond the level
of a normal human that said because
dabi's nomu parts were only on the
outside they're only skin-deep if you
will his actual mind was not affected by
this procedure on top of this nomu twist
ujiko states that a major reason why
dobby's body has managed to overcome
death is his obsession for revenge
against endeavor in that sense his body
was being held together by the flames of
vengeance although i mean that is not a
very scientific explanation so i assume
that it's more symbolic of dobby's state
of mind than an actual reason why he
managed to keep his body together back
in kamino dabi tells shoto that he did
go home after escaping from that
facility even then three years after the
fire daby who was still toya at the time
wanted to be acknowledged by his father
but when he arrived back at the todoroki
house he saw endeavour training with
shoto not only that but he was being
brutal with shoto as if he learned
nothing from the tragedy that happened
to toya this made toya thing that his
father had already moved on from him he
was too busy training shoto and putting
all of his efforts into shoto and it was
like toya never even existed toya didn't
even matter because shoto was the new
star of the show and the family had
simply moved on from toya and not only
that but what happened to toya didn't
make endeavour stop and think twice
about putting his children through so
much suffering shoto just became the new
toya in endeavour's mind toya was
replaced and forgotten and this made him
feel even worse now we know that things
weren't actually that simple toya's
mother never got over what happened to
him and neither did his siblings even
endeavour was devastated by the loss but
because he didn't know what else to do
with his grief he channeled everything
into training shoto this was obviously a
terrible and counterproductive way of
dealing with the tragedy and shoto ended
up suffering even more because of it it
goes without saying that endeavour made
many many mistakes and did many many bad
things so toya does have a point here
but it just isn't as simple as he thinks
after witnessing what he believed to be
evidence that his family moved on from
him dobby stopped being obsessed with
making endeavor proud however he
replaced that obsession with an
obsession for revenge against endeavor
he spent all of his time trying to make
his flames stronger without regard for
the damage he was doing to his own body
and he also carefully studied all of
endeavour's actions as a top pro hero in
order to learn all of his moves this is
when toyah died and dabi was born ujiko
explains that dabi is a completely
different villain from someone like all
for one all for one is a master
strategist who wants to avoid death and
live forever on the other hand dabi is
an obsessed berserker driven by revenge
and he will gladly embrace death if it
will allow him to fulfill his desire for
vengeance unlike all for one dobby is
self-destructive and insane and as the
chapter brings us back to kamino we see
that dabi has essentially turned himself
into a flaming corpse a fiery human nomu
this new completely out of control dobby
vows that he will burn everything
precious to endeavor down to the ground
and this act will serve as proof that he
existed this will be dobby's revenge for
the fact that endeavour had forgotten
him and replaced him with shoto it is
clearly implied that dobby is prepared
to give up his own life to kill shoto
and he will fight until the bitter end
without any regard for his own
well-being as shoto proclaims that he is
not going to let dobby do anything like
this the chapter comes to an end and wow
we have gotten hints about dobby's
demented state of mind before but this
chapter has just taken all of that to
the next level dobby is clearly ready to
burn himself to death in the name of
revenge and when you have such an
overpowered villain who is willing to
fight to death it could lead to absolute
disaster for the heroes i mean how do
you deal with a villain who has flame
attacks that put even endeavors flames
to shame and a complete lack of concern
for his own life like yes shoto is going
to try to deal with him but it will not
be easy dobby is literally built
different he is a fanatical extremist
when it comes to his thirst for revenge
and so conventional logic and strategy
don't really apply to him what do you
guys think is going to happen now dobby
isn't trying to win a fight or get out
of this alive he just wants to see the
world burn himself included what do you
guys think is going to happen now is
shoto going to succeed in taking dobby
down or is dobby going to destroy
himself while also taking a bunch of
heroes down with him in the process is
this the beginning of the end for dobby
is he going to go out in a blazing
inferno or will he actually survive this
battle also what did you guys think of
dobby implying that the procedures that
were performed on him were similar to
the procedures and technology that
created the nomu to me it sounded like
he's a human nomu hybrid it sounded like
he has no muesque alterations performed
on his body but on the outside only so
because of that his mind wasn't affected
by the procedure because nothing was
done to him on the inside do you guys
agree with this interpretation let me
know down below finally how messed up is
it that all for one and ujiko
essentially had an orphanage where they
groomed the children to become spare
vessels for all for one and they even
tried to convince the children that they
were all part of some cult-like family
man all for one really has been weaving
his evil plans for decades and he wasn't
kidding when he said that he always had
multiple backup plans
now i wonder if that kid with wings from
deku's childhood who was said to be
ujjiko's grandson was actually just
another kid from this orphanage there is
a theory out there that the kid was
turned into the winged nomu from the
stain arc but i thought that maybe his
quirk was just cloned and given to the
nomu because we know now that ujico
knows how to clone quirks
but after this crazy reveal i'm not so
sure i would not be surprised if fujiko
really turned some of these kids into
nomu once they stopped being useful to
him which is truly messed up stuff
if you guys enjoyed this video and you
want to see more mha content in the
future do me a quick favor and leave a
like and comment it only takes a second
but it really helps with that youtube
algorithm and remember that subscribing
and hitting that bell is a completely
free but very real way of directly
supporting the channel you can also hit
me up on twitter and instagram at anime
uproar i want to give a big thank you to
all of our anime outro patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thank you to kyle salisbury he
is an absolute mad lad and a disciple of
lord twigo himself and i can't forget
all of our the one tier patrons the ones
who stand above all other clans
including alpha sigma pate heffa the
red-haired fox hinokamian water the
toasted chi corey mcgowan the fallen
chosen spidey life tinel tungsten tarkis
and baked buddhist finally thank you
also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh on
hell crews alicia octor bonnie parks fat
boy games kaido might be a duck jessica
rabbit ollyvania and mando if you guys
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you